NARRATOR: On April 14, 1865,
President Abraham Lincoln
was shot
[gun shot]
And killed by this guy--
John Wilkes Booth, a
well-known stage actor
and Confederate sympathizer.
What you might not know is
that after firing his gun,
he fled the scene of
the crime with one
of the biggest manhunts
in US history on his tail.
After 12 days on the run,
he was finally caught.
Here's how.
After shooting the
president, Booth
jumped from the
presidential box yelling
JOHN WILKES BOOTH:
"Sic semper tyrannis!"
NARRATOR: Which
translates roughly to--
JOHN WILKES BOOTH: "Thus
always to tyrants."
NARRATOR: With a broken
leg, he still manages
to run across the stage and
exit through a side door, where
his horse was waiting for him
[whinnying]
Around 4 AM the next morning,
Booth and his accomplice,
David Harold, arrived at
Dr. Samuel Mudd's house.
Dr. Mudd was also a
Confederate sympathizer,
but he didn't know
Booth had shot Lincoln.
He put Booth's leg in a splint.
When Mudd saw the
paper the next morning,
he realized he was
housing a fugitive
and insisted his
two guest leave.
[horse galloping]
So Booth and Harold
ventured into Zekiah Swamp.
They managed to hide for four
days in a dense pine thicket,
while more than 1,000 union
soldiers searched for them.
Confederate sympathizers
helped the two
fugitives cross the Potomac
and the Rappahannock Rivers.
Booth and Harold
then took refuge
on a farm in eastern
Maryland, pretending to be
wounded Confederate soldiers.
But a tip led Union
troops to the tobacco barn
where Booth was sleeping.
They lit the barn on fire.
Booth tried to shoot his way
out, but was shot in the neck.
He died a few hours later.
Soon after, four of his
co-conspirators were hanged.
Booth's body was eventually
returned to his relatives,
and he was buried
in the family plot.
Today, people leave pennies
on his unmarked grave,
giving Lincoln the last word.